[Music]
study lab is over there to go hook mom
I'm not going anywhere
[Music]
whose foster care spits me out I'm gone
nobody's ever real you know my best
friend isn't even real tell me about it
that hurts my feelings tell me where
you're really from Mars I was born here
yeah sometimes I feel like I'm from a
different planet too
I want to go to her he's met less than
15 people he's being denied connection
his physical development is at the
perfect place to do it he's hard to
can't handle our gravity it's too risky
it's worth it
there's so many tours hi oh wait funky
okay are you a transfer student okay
excuse me that's our emergency eyewash
station
so uh Gardner here from Mars yeah Tulsa
my mother was an astronaut she died on
Mars giving birth to me but this is my
father you're gonna help me find him
people have been lying to me my entire
life because something's out crazy
doesn't mean it's not true
Oh Flores it's just a horse I'm on a
road trip with an insane person
he's running out of time
only come with me now no this is my life
gardener gardener
[Music]
we found it let's go
friend of yours
you hate me human and no matter what
happens it was worth it
all of it
[Music]
we were very proud of yourself
a life I'd forgotten you okay
I had another family